d'abord je voudrais dire une chose sur
la réforme constitutionnelle il faut
arrêter les discussions en catimini qui
par exemple se mène en ce moment dans le
bureau du président larcher groupe de
travail d'accord mais il faut faire non
mais c'est plus que ça ils sont en train
de chercher un compromis sans qui aucune
discussion publique entre le
gouvernement et la droite du sénat moi
je dis maintenant il faut mener ce débat
au grand jour faut que tout le monde
mette ses idées sur la table parce que
si on veut changer la constitution c'est
une question sérieuse que ne peuvent pas
régler quelques personnes et celle par
la réforme et la réforme le chemin
qu'elle prend et nous inquiète parce
qu'elle vise à vider encore là le
maillage démocratique du préfet au
profit de la concentration toujours dans
la dans l'est dans les hautes sphères de
l'état et je pense que c'est archaïque
comme vision de la république
aujourd'hui au 26 n'attaque contre le
parlement
oui aussi on voit bien d'ailleurs on
veut encore réduire la discussion en
séance publique
on veut passer de plus en plus de texte
en commission on veut nous faire
travailler toujours plus vite en étant
moins nombreux